HEARING FOR THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE. AND
SO SOME OF THE JOYSTICKS AND
PROTOCOLS- DUE TO THE
CONTINUING COVE IN NINETEEN
CRISIS- WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE IN
THIS- THIS COMMITTEE ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
YOU KNOW FOR THOSE HERE IN
ATTENDANCE TODAY BOTH. HEARING
SOME PARTICIPANTS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC PLEASE KNOW THAT
THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING FACE
COVERINGS ARE REQUIRED TO BE
WORN AT ALL TIMES. AND SIX FEET
A PHYSICAL DISTANCE IT IS
EXPECTED TO MAINTAIN TO BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
FACE COVERING ONE CAN BE.
PROVIDED TO YOU. THROUGH THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
REQUIREMENTS WE UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE LIMITED SATING AVAILABLE
IN THIS HEARING ROOM. AND WE
WILL BE- CAREFULLY MONITORING
CAPACITY THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING. THERE ARE SEVEN BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA THIS MORNING-
FOUR OF WHICH ARE PROPOSED- AS
PART OF- OUR CONSENT CALENDAR A
FOR EACH ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
THEY'LL BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT COMMENTS MAY BE
MADE HERE IN PERSON IN THIS
ROOM BY PHONE OR FROM A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS ARE OUTSIDE
OF THIS HEARING ROOM ON THE
NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL THE
STATIONS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES AS WELL AS
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PHONE
NUMBERTO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
WILL BE SHOWN OR PROVIDED TO
VIEWERS ON SCREEN THROUGHOUT
THIS HEARING HOW THE PHONE
NUMBER WILL ALSO BE POSTED ON
OUR SIMPLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
FOR THOSE WHO WILL BE- MAKING
SOME COMMENTS THIS MORNING AND
WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND IF APPLICABLE.
THE ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT.
AND IF YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL THAT IS UNDER- COMPAC
CONSIDERATION. ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WHO IS ALSO WELCOME
TO SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
OUR COMMITTEE THROUGH EMAIL.
EMAILS MAY BE SENT TO THE
ADDRESS FOUND ON OUR WEBSITE
WHICH IS A G. R. I. DOT
COMMITTEE. AT ASM DOT CA DOT G.
O. V. IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
THE GOAL OF HEARING AS MUCH
FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN THE
LIMITS OF OUR TIME. WE WILL
NOT. PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS THAT- THAT DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF OUR HEARING. AND THE
PROCEEDINGS OF THIS YEAR.
PLEASE BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS
OF THESE RULES MAY BE SUBJECT.
TO YOUR REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT- TO PROCESSES BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE OF SOUTH.
AND SO- WITH THAT- AND SO WITH
THAT AS I MENTIONED WE DO HAVE
FOR BILLS THAT ARE- ARE
PROPOSED FOR COULD SAY CALENDAR
WILL WAIT TILL HE STOPS QUORUM-
BUT THOSE FOR BILLS ARE ITEM
THREE A. B. A FIVE ONE NINE BY
SOME THE WOMAN IRWIN- ITEM
FIVE. A. B. AND NINE TWO ZERO
BY SOME THE WOMAN CECILIA YOUR
CURRENT ITEM SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE THREE SIX TWO SOME THE
WOMAN CARILLO AND ITEM SEVEN
WHICH IS A COMMITTEE BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN ONE NINE-
AND SO WITH THAT- I. DON'T SEE
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER- GARCIA HERE
IS THE FIRST ITEM NOT A REASON
HALL. YEAH LET'S GO- WE CAN GO
TO FILE ITEM TO. WHICH IS A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLEW UP THEIR
GUNS. RENDON. EDUARDO AND SO
PRIOR TO THIS ITEM WE DO HAVE
SIX MEMBERS SO IF WE CAN
ESTABLISH- QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS HERE
MATHIS AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM
LAURA. GRAY IRWIN JONES SAWYER
HERE LEVINE BE ABLE TO OFFER
WHAT. WE HAVE A PARKING
FANTASTIC AND AS WAS MENTIONED
WE HAVE- FOR ITEMS ON OUR COULD
TAKE COUNTER CAN I GET A MOTION
FOR THOSE ITEMS. SO MUCH AS I
CAN I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
HI RIVERSIDE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
CUNNINGHAM FLORA FLORA I AGREE
IRWIN JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE LEVINE WE ARE PUT
OFF WOOD WE HAVE SIX FOOT THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY WITH THAT
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- GARCIA
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MOTIONS SECOND I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF POINTS I JUST WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT ARE
IMPORTANT- TO ADDRESS WHY THIS
BILL BEFORE YOU AB SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT AS YOU CAN SEE IS A
BIPARTISAN. BILL THAT DEALS
WITH THIS STATE INSTITUTIONS
AND THE PROCUREMENT OF
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS CURRENT
LAW DIRECTS OUR INSTITUTIONS TO
GIVE PREFERENCE FOR FOOD GROWN
STATE WHEN THE PRICE OF
CALIFORNIA PURPOSE DOES NOT
EXCEED THE ESTATE PRODUCE BY
MORE THAN FIVE PERCENT. HOWEVER
THE LAW EXEMPTS OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS UNIVERSITIES WHICH ARE
AMONG THE LARGEST INSTITUTIONAL
PURCHASERS OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS WILL THE FEDERAL LONG
TO THE BUY AMERICA PROVISION
THAT REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO PURCHASE DOMESTIC
COMMODITIES AND PRODUCTS FOR
SCHOOL MEALS LOOPHOLES IN THE
LAW ALLOW SCHOOLS TO PURCHASE
CHEAPER FOREIGN PRODUCTS
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA GROWN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS FOR
EXAMPLE. SACRAMENTO BEE
STARRING TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
FOUNDED SACRAMENTO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT PURCHASE CANNED
PEACHES AND MIXED FRUIT FROM
CHINA AND VIOLATION OF BUY
AMERICA POLICIES EVEN THOUGH
NEARLY ALL US CANNED PEACHES
AND PLASTIC PACKAGES OF PEACHES
ARE HERE GROWN IN CALIFORNIA-
FURTHER MORE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE STATE LOTTERY
SHOULD REPORT THAT FOUND THAT
NONE OF THE SIX SCHOOL
DISTRICTS REVIEWED. HAD
ADEQUATE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES TO IMPLEMENT BUY
AMERICAN LAWS AND THEY HAD
PURCHASE FOREIGN SOURCED ITEMS
BUT DID NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
DOCUMENTATION TO JUSTIFY THOSE
PURCHASES DESPITE OUR STATE
AGRICULTURAL BOUNTY PRODUCERS
FOR FACE COMPETITION FROM NON
DOMESTIC PRODUCERS IN CHINA AND
MEXICO AND OTHER NATIONS THAT
DO NOT HAVE THE SAME LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTIONS OR
QUALITY CONTROL AS WE DO.
CALIFORNIA SITUATION SPEND
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY ON FOOD PURCHASING IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE
ESTIMATED TO SPEND BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED ANNUALLY SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY- TO ON DIRECT
FOOD PURCHASES THAT IS NEARLY
ONE BILLION THAT THE STATE
COULD BE DIRECTED TOWARD
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA FARMERS
AND FARMWORKERS BY PURCHASING
CALIFORNIA GROWN FOOD. A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT WOOD DIRECTOR
STATE INSTITUTIONS AND SCHOOLS
TO PURCHASE CALIFORNIA GROWN
FOOD WHEN AVAILABLE. AND WERE
NOT AVAILABLE THEY WOULD BE
WIRED TO GET. TO US GROW FOOD
OVER FOREIGN FOOD. CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY BENEFITS WHEN THE STATE
INSTITUTIONS DIRECT PURCHASING
POWER TOWARD CALIFORNIA GROWN
PRODUCTS AND FARMERS
REINVESTMENT. BACK INTO THEIR
CENTER WORKFORCE THE ECONOMY
AND THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. WE
SHOULD BE GIVING OUR FARMERS
THE BENEFIT OF DOUBT THAT OUR
STATE AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS ARE
THE BEST IN THE NATION. BY
COMMITTING TO BUY CALIFORNIA
GROWN PRODUCTS THIS BILL ENJOYS
SUPPORT. OF EVERY COUNTY FARM
BUREAU IN EVERY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE FROM THE IN AN EMPIRE.
ONE TO JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I WANT TO THANK-
THE TEAM HERE OF THIS COMEDIAN
YOURSELF MISTER CHAIR. AS YOU
ARE AWARE MAYBE OTHERS ARE WE
HAVE MERGED A B. TEN TWENTY
FIVE- WITH THIS BILL A BILL
THAT YOU AUTHORED. TO ENSURE
THAT FIFTY PERCENT. OF PRODUCTS
ARE PURCHASED HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES WE'VE MET WITH
THE- AD COUNCIL WHO'S A SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND- I SEEM TO BE
ALIGNING OUR INTENTIONS QUITE
WELL. WE'VE ALSO BEEN TALKING
TO SEVERAL FLOCKS HE REPRESENTS
UNION MADE. AND HAVE ADDRESSED
MANY OF HER CONCERNS AFFECT OUR
TEAM MET WITH HER YESTERDAY.
AND ALSO I BELIEVE THERE IS AN
EXEMPTION FOR THE CANNED FOOD-
INDUSTRY AREAS THAT THAT THEY
ASKED FOR AN EXEMPTION. ON THIS
BILL I'M HOPING THAT THAT WE
CAN GET YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND
MOVE THIS- THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND ON THE GOVERNOR'S. DESK
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I THANK
YOU SEVEN MEMBER- WE HAVE- TO
WIN ASSISTANCE. WE HAVE A RICH-
HUDGINS WITH THE IT WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
KENNY PEACH ASSOCIATION AND
CELESTE ALONZO GENERAL MANAGER
OF JUNIOR ENTERPRISES LLC
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE-
CONNECT OUR WITNESSES. YES
WITNESSES LINES ARE OPEN THANK.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS RICH
HUTCHINS PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNING PEACH
ASSOCIATION WERE A GROWER OWNED
MARKETING IN BARGAINING
COOPERATIVE WE REPRESENTS
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED GROWERS-
WHO PRODUCE 75% OF CALIFORNIANS
CLING PEACH CROP. DESPITE
CLAIMS BY GEORGIA CALIFORNIA IS
THE REAL PEACH STATE PRODUCING
NEARLY 1100% OF THE NATION'S
DOMESTIC CAN'T PEACH AND
PLASTIC PACKAGED PEACH SUPPLY.
OUR INDUSTRY HAS BEEN IN A
STATE OF DECLINE- FOR DECADES
NOW PRIMARILY AS A RESULT OF
SUBSIDIZED FOREIGN IMPORTS
PRIMARILY FROM CHINA DISPLACING.
U. S. GROWERS WE'VE SEEN A 50%
DECREASE IN ACREAGE OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS- THE LATEST
PROCESSOR CASUALTY IN OUR
INDUSTRY OCCURRED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHEN SENECA
FOODS CLOSE THEIR MODESTO
CANNERY- AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT PLANT CLOSURE. NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED LONG TIME
EMPLOYEES WITH AN AVERAGE
TENURE OF OVER TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OF EMPLOYMENT LOST THEIR
JOBS- IN ADDITION TO MANY OTHER
SEASONAL PROCESSING JOBS IN THE
FACILITY. WE'RE EXPRESSING OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR LEGISLATION
ENSURING THAT TAXPAYER DOLLARS
ARE SPENT FOR FOOD PURCHASES
WHICH BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
GROWERS AND PROTECT UNION JOBS.
IN PROCESSING PLANTS IN PACKING
HOUSES THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AT THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
EVEN FOLLOWING THE SENECA PLANT
CLOSURES TODAY FOR CANNING
ACCOUNTS FOR MORE THAN EIGHT
THOUSAND UNION JOBS. THIS
ACTION WOULD BETTER ALIGN
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD PROCUREMENT
POLICY WITH BY AMERICAN DIRECT
IS OUTLINED IN PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH
EXECUTIVE ORDER. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AT THIS POINT LET ME
DEPART BRIEFLY FROM MY PREPARED
REMARKS AND JUST NOTE THAT
DURING HIS JOINT ADDRESS TO
CONGRESS LAST NIGHT. PRESIDENT
BIDEN IN DESCRIBING HIS
AMERICAN JOBS PLAN NOTED THAT
IT WOULD BE GUIDED BY ONE
PRINCIPLE BY AMERICAN. HE
CONTINUED NOTING. AMERICAN TAX
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO BE USED TO
BUY AMERICAN PRODUCTS MADE IN
AMERICA TO CREATE AMERICAN
JOBS. THAT'S THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE AND IT WILL BE
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION. HE
CONTINUED SAYING HI I MADE IT
CLEAR TO MY CABINET THIRD
PLEASE GIVE EXEMPTIONS HAS BEEN
STRENUOUSLY LIMITED IT WILL BE
AMERICAN PRODUCTS. WE APPLAUD
THIS STATEMENT BY THE PRESIDENT
IN OUR VIEW THIS IS THE TIME
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
WITH ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA TO
CRAFT WORKABLE LEGISLATION
ENSURING THAT TAXPAYER DOLLARS
ARE SPENT ON AMERICAN GROWN
FOOD PRODUCTS. WHICH SUPPORTS
OUR FARMERS. VERTEX UNION JOBS
IN PROCESSING FACILITIES BY THE
WAY MANY OF WHICH ARE LOCATED
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WHILE PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH
THE SAFEST FOOD AVAILABLE. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON A. B. SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MUCH APPRECIATED- MISALIGNED SO
IF YOU ARE PREPARED FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS THOUGHT THAT ONE DAY
WHEN I AM THE GENERAL MANAGER
FOR MY FAMILY FARM JUNIOR
ENTERPRISES LLC IN COACHELLA.
MY GRANDPA BEGAN FARMING IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES ALONG WITH MY
DAD JUNIOR. MY TWIN BROTHER AND
I LEFT THE COLLEGE AND RETURN
TO WORK ON THE FAMILY FARM. NOW
MY TWIN BELIEVES ALONG WITH A
THIRD HOUSING FAMILIES ALONG
THE FORTY. UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
NOT KNOW IF MY NEPHEW LITTLE
WHO WE WILL BE ABLE TO HELP
CONTINUE THE FAMILY BUSINESS
DUE TO STRICT REGULATIONS
CALIFORNIA HAS GONE OUR CULTURE.
ALONG WITH THE REGULATIONS WE
INCUR THE COSTS OF HEALTHCARE
FOR EMPLOYEES WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND THE RISING
MINIMUM WAGE. ARE GROWING COST
HAVE BECOME EXPONENTIALLY
HIGHER IN THE LAST YEARS AT A
TIME TO MAKE WE ARE STRUGGLING.
WE NEED TO THE PARK CALIFORNIA
GROWERS BY MANDATING THAT OUR
STATE INSTITUTIONS BY
CALIFORNIA FIRST BEFORE
IMPORTING PRODUCE FROM OTHER
STATES OR COUNTRIES. WE WANT TO
CONTINUE GROWING BUT STATES
LIKE TEXAS AND ARIZONA DO NOT
HAVE TO CONTEND WITH THE SAME
REGULATIONS CALIFORNIA HAS ON
OUR CULTURE. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
STRICTEST REGULATIONS IN THE
COUNTRY ESPECIALLY THE
CONSEQUENCES. AND IT'S NOT THAT
WE ARE PLENTY REGULATIONS WE
ARE PROUD THAT OUR STATE IS A
LEADER IN PROTECTING OUR
ENVIRONMENT OUR WORKERS IN OUR
COUNTRY VERY. HOWEVER BEING A
LEADER HAS AN ECONOMIC COST TO
GROWERS ALL WE ARE ASKING THE
FORESTRY PRODUCERS FIRST
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
THAT ARE GOING SAFELY AND
PROVIDING LIVING WAGES. I HAVE
THE HONOR OF BEING PART OF
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM. ANY
PROGRAMS I HAD THE CHANCE TO
VISIT OTHER STATES SUCH AS
TEXAS AND GEORGIA AND WITNESS
HOW AGRICULTURE THREE GIVEN THE
FATE. AND THERE ARE FARMERS OUR
HEROES. FARMERS RIGHT TO
FURTHER TABLES. ON THE
GOVERNMENT TURNED HELP FARMERS.
DUBLIN GEORGIA. DO NOT HAVE TO
PAY TAXES ON THE- I'M NOT
ASKING FOR CALIFORNIA TO CLEAR
THOSE HEROES BUT YOU'RE NOT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO OUR JOB.
WILL BE TO FEED OUR STATE AND
WE NEED HELP. BY BUYING
CALIFORNIA ITS WITH THE KEY A
FUTURE. I NEXT GROWING SEASON.
THIS WILL KEEP OUR CULTURE
ALIVE IN OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE.
IT WILL ALSO KEEP OUR EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYED AND HOPEFULLY LITTLE
THE WE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE A
FABRICANTE MY GRANDPA. MY DAD
AND MYSELF HAVE A HOME. THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME WILL PUT
IT UP FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO. PROVIDE US SOME COMMENTS. A
FIRST DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEE
NON- WE WILL- GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATED WE HAVE CALLERS
IN THE QUEUE. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YES. THANK YOU YES AND
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO RECORDED A LINE
OF FIFTY NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CARE NUMBERS
TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
SUPPORT. AMICORE LINE. FIFTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MR KAREN
MEMBERS TURKEY GARINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA ONE THING THAT WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
YEAH BURKE AND YET STOP FOR
WORKING WITH US AS WELL AS THE
NEW THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF AND WITH THE LATEST
AMENDMENT THANK YOU FOR THE
SUPPORT OF. AB SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT THANK YOU. AN ONLINE
NUMBER SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DAVID JOHNSON COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS WE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTIAN ACTUALLY ON
BEHALF OF JULIE DELPY WE ALSO
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT. OKAY I'LL. LINE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHRIS CON REPRESENTING
THE COACHELLA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. LINE.
EIGHTY TWO. CHANCE. FOR
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE BILL
NUMBERS. SEVEN WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT AWARENESS
WEEK WEEK WEEK. I BELIEVE IT'S
SEVENTY EIGHT THIS IS GEORGE
TUTOR WITH TUDOR MANSION
COACHELLA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT. THE JOB
ORDER LINES. SIXTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING HERNANDEZ CALIFORNIA
PHARMA FOUNDATION THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT.
LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME'S ANTHONY BIANCO
ORDERING AT THE INEYARDS
REFORM OF THE COACHELLA VALLEY
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT. LINE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS ELECT THE HEALTHY WITH
CALIFORNIA TRIP MUTUAL SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IN LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES YOU KNOW PERCY GROWING
COACHELLA VALLEY AND I SUPPORT.
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT. LINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ADAM
BORCHARD WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT. LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE DENNIS JOHNSON
FROM SEAVIEW PACKING WE GROW
CITRUS IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WE ARE DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND
LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TONY BIANCO FROM
DESERT FRESH INK IN COACHELLA
VALLEY ALL SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MADAM
OPERATOR AND WITH THAT WE GET
BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SO MANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. IF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE UP WITH WHAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- THANK I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS I
MEAN. I APPRECIATE THE TWO
SPEAKERS. ESPECIALLY THE FIRST
ONE THAT- WHEN HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THOSE CANNERY JOBS AND
MEAN. ASSEMBLY FLOOR UP. IN HIS
DISTRICT YOU KNOW HAD A LOT OF
THE WORMS WERE NEXT DOOR TO WE
LOST THOSE TWO WE HAD MANY WHEN
WE LOST OURS AND THEY WERE IN
MODESTO A LOT OF OUR WORKERS
HAD TO TRAVEL. DO YOU HAVE FOR
THOSE JOBS AND- THEY'RE THEY'RE
GONNA. SHOW I APPRECIATE- THE
FACT THAT THIS IS. ANOTHER WAY
OF US YOU KNOW TRYING TO
PROTECT. THE FOLKS THAT ARE
HERE WORKING HARD TRAVELING TO
THEIR JOBS AND- THANK YOU OR
SOMEONE SIXTEEN THANK YOU FOR
THE FOR THIS BILL PROJECT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IDEA GROUP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRING THIS
FOURTEEN YOU KNOW ME I'M GONNA
HELP DEFEND OUR FARMERS AND OUR
PRODUCTS THAT ARE HERE IN
RACING CALIFORNIA- APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS FORWARD IN
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE WITH THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY AND I'D ALSO
LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR. K. OKAY
ANY OTHER. COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MATHIS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- IS TO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WORK IN BEING A
PARTNER ON THIS IS WELL ON I
KNOW MYSELF AND SHARE AND-
THERE'S A LOT THAT'S GONE INTO
THIS AND A LOT THAT'S BEEN
LOOKED AT TO MAKE SURE ALL THE
BASES ARE COVERED. YOU KNOW.
GROW BUY LOCAL AND WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT BUYING LOCAL IS.
EVERYONE OF THOSE DOLLARS ARE
SPENT ANOTHER FOUR SEVEN TIMES
IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY SO
THAT'S ALL MONEY COMING BACK
AND CALIFORNIA'S POCKETS SO- MR
GARCIA I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK IN YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
AND- THE CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU. OKAY YEAH AND- WITH
THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE. THE CLOSE
SOME YES THANK YOU CHAIR AGAIN
TO HELP CREATE THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE THE AMENDMENTS PUT
FORWARD YOUR COLLABORATION AND
MERGING THESE TWO BILLS- WHAT
THE GOALS THAT YOU HAD SET
FORWARD I THINK- IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THIS BILL WE WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS WE'VE- PUT THAT TRULY
CALIFORNIA'S- PRODUCTION FRONT
AND CENTER. WHENIT COMES TO
PROCUREMENT AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT WE HAVE YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE BEST- QUALITY CONTROL
MEASURES IN PLACE THERE'S OF NO
DOUBT THAT WE PASSED THE SOME
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS. FOR
PURPOSES OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS IT
RELATES TO CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WITHOUT A DOUBT
WE HAVE YOU KNOW THE MOST
COMMITTED WORK FORCE IN THE
AREA OF AGRICULTURE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS ENSURE THAT- WE
KEEP EIGHT ROBUST AND GROWING
AGRICULTURAL. INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT WE AS A
STATE TAKE AND PLAY A ROLE IN
ENSURING THAT THAT HAPPENS MANY
OF US REPRESENT- DISTRICTS THAT
MAKE UP AGRICULTURAL ECONOMIES-
IN THE- KIND OF FRONT AND
CENTER OF WHAT DRIVES THE
ENGINE THERE LOCALLY AND WE'VE
SEEN SLOWLY THE DWINDLING OF
THOSE JOBS- FOR MANY REASONS-
FOREIGN COMPETITION BEING ONE
OF THE- BIGGEST ONES. AND SO
HERE WE HAVE THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR MOUTH IS LITERALLY
AND MAKING SURE THAT- WE ARE
PROTECTING- THE AGRICULTURAL-
ACTIVITIES THAT THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED AND- KEEPING OUR HIGH
STANDARDS ON THE ENVIRONMENT.
ON LABOR PROTECTIONS AND
QUALITY CONTROL- WHEN IT COMES
TO PROTECTING CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE THE
CALIFORNIANS WILL- SUPPORT AT
THE IDEA OF BUYING CALIFORNIA
PRODUCE FIRST THAT'S WHY THIS
BILLS BEFORE YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I WELCOME ALL OF
YOU- IN THE AG COMMITTEE- TO
JOIN ME AS CO AUTHORS ON THIS
BILL. VERY GOOD SO- WROTE
REALLY. ALL THE WORK AS VICE
CHAIR MATHIS STATED A LOT OF
WORK HAS BEEN INVESTED IN THE
SAFFORD APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION WITH SO MANY
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS. THIS
BILL DOES HAVE A DO PASS AS
AMENDED RECOMMENDATION- THERE
WAS A MOTION BY CELL NUMBER
FLOOR SECOND BYE BYE SURE
MATHIS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ONE ITEM ONE A.
B. SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT EDUARDO
GARCIA- MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MMBER RIVAS. HI RIVAS
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I'VE
LARA. LARA I AGREE- ONE IRWIN
AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER
AYE LEVINE LEVINE IDEA PUT OFF
BY THE APPROVED RAW I WOULD.
WHAT I THAT HAS TEN VOTE
DOESN'T THE MASSACRE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU THINGS ON THE- NEXT
WAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER TO SEND
THE BILL ONE TWO EIGHT TWO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM. WE ARE
READY WHEN YOU ARE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I.
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY TAKING A
MOMENT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR CONTINUED
EFFORTS WORKING WITH US ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TO THE CALIFORNIA PATH
BLOOD MATT BANK PET BLOOD BANK
MODERNIZATION ACT. SEEKS TO
ADDRESS BOTH THE SHORTAGE OF
ANIMAL BLOOD FOR VETERINARY
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE AND PHASE
OUT THE OBSOLETE INHUMANE
PRACTICE OF CAPTIVE CLOSED
COLONY CANINE BLOOD BANKS IN
OUR STATE. IT DOES THIS BY
AUTHORIZING CALIFORNIA LICENSED
VETERINARIANS TO OPERATE
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS. TO
PRODUCE AND SELL OR TRANSFER
ANIMAL BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS.
VETERINARY TECHNICIANS AND
VETERINARY ASSISTANCE MAY ALSO
COLLECT THE BLOOD FROM AN
ANIMAL UNDER DIRECT OR INDIRECT
SUPERVISION OF A LICENSED
VETERINARIAN. THE BILL WOULD
PLACE THE PRACTICE OF COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKING UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OVERSIGHT OF THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD. AND
MODERNIZES CALIFORNIA LAW BY
PROVIDING A SAFE ETHICALLY
SOURCED ANIMAL BLOOD SUPPLY FOR
USE IN VETERINARY PRACTICE.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKS AND THESE ARE
SIMILAR TO HUMAN BLOOD BANKS IN
THE SENSE THAT IT ALLOWS BLOOD
COLLECTION FROM PETS WHOSE
OWNERS HAVE VOLUNTARILY
CONSENTED TO THE DONATION.
CURRENTLY THIS VOLUNTARY
COMMUNITY BASED APPROACHES AND
ALLOWED IN CALIFORNIA INSTEAD
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY THAT REQUIRES
ANIMAL BLOOD TO COME FROM SO
CALLED CLOSED COLONY BLOOD
BANKS. THESE ARE BLOOD BANKS
THAT SOURCE BLOOD FROM ANIMALS
CAPPED HOUSED AND MAINTAINED OR
MAINTAINED AT A FACILITY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF COLLECTING THEIR
BLOOD. THESE CLOTHES QUALITY
BLOOD BANKS REQUIRE HUNDREDS OF
ANIMALS TO BE IN CAGES FOR
YEARS WHILE THEIR BLOOD IS
ROUTINELY HARVESTED WITH ANIMAL
BLOOD DEMANDS ONLY INCREASING
IN THE STATE. I'M PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT CLOSE CALLING
THE CONDITIONS THAT KEEP DOGS
CAGED IN TIGHT SPACES DEPRIVED
OF EXERCISE AND MENTAL
STIMULATION. AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO ALLOWS FOR A MORE HUMANE
SOLUTION FOR SOURCING ANIMAL
BLOOD WHILE ALSO ESTABLISHING
CONDITIONS TO EVENTUALLY PHASE
OUT CAPTIVE CLOSE COLONY CANINE
BLOOD BANKS. AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO WAS RECENTLY AMENDED TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE RAISED IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS OVER THE YEARS. THE
BILL NOW INSURERS THAT
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS FOLLOWED
THE BEST MOST RECENT CLINICAL
PRACTICES AND STANDARDS FOR
VETERINARY TRANSFUSION MEDICINE
AND DIRECTS THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD. TO UPON
APPROPRIATION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE HIRE A CONSULTANT
TO ASSIST IN DEVELOPING
GUIDELINES AND BEST PRACTICES
FOR VETERINARIANS TO FOLLOW
WHEN OPERATING COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANKS. THOSE MOST AFFECTED BY
THIS LEGISLATION OF THE
VETERINARIANS MUST HAVE
RELIABLE SOURCES OF BLOOD AND
BLOOD COMPONENTS TO SAVE THE
LIVES OF DOGS AND CATS IN OUR
HOSPITALS. ONE OF THE MAJOR
CONCERNS OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IS ENSURING THAT
BLOOD AND BLOOD PRODUCTS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE ONCE
THIS LAWS IMPLEMENTED AND THE
QUALITY OF THESE PRODUCTS IS
MAINTAINED. AND MY STAFF AND I
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE C. VMA AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF FINDING THE
APPROPRIATE TRIGGER FOR THE
PHASE OUT OF THE CLOSE COLONY
MODEL. AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
WOULD EVENTUALLY PHASE OUT AND
ELIMINATE THE USE OF CAPTIVE
CLOSED COLONY CANINE BLOOD
BANKS IN CALIFORNIA ONCE IT IS
DETERMINED. THAT THE COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKS ARE PRODUCING EQUAL
TO OR EXCEEDING THE SUPPLY OF
BLOOD THAT'S PRODUCED BY
CAPTIVE BLOOD BANKS. THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT SENATOR WILL CAN I
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
PASSIONATELY FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS AND IT IS OUR HOPE THAT
THIS WIL BE THE YEAR THAT
VETERINARIANS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE AFFECTED
STATE DEPARTMENTS CAN ALL AGREE
THAT AN ETHICALLY SOURCED SAFE.
AND EXPANDED ANIMAL SUPPLY
ANIMAL BLOOD SUPPLY FOR
VETERINARY USE IS NECESSARY AND
INDEED POSSIBLE. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO PASSED OUT OF
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY LAST WEEK
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT THE VET
MATT BOARD VOTED FIVE TO TWO TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND FUNDED.
CALLING IN THIS MORNING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ARE DOCTOR CAN PAWLOWSKI
CLINICAL DIRECTOR AT INSIGHT
VETERINARY WELLNESS CENTER. AND
DR JEANINE BERGER SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF RESCUE AND WELFARE
AT THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND-
WITH THAT YEAH WE DO HAVE- WHEN
THIS IS SUPPORT OPERATOR CAN
YOU- MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN ACT
AS WITNESSES PLEASE. BUT LINES
ARE OPEN THANK YOU. THIS IS
DOCTOR CLOUT YEAH I WILL GO
AHEAD AND START IF THAT'S OKAY
YES PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
TESTIFYING TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO TO HELP INCREASE AND
ASSURE THE ADEQUATE SAFE SUPPLY
OF CANINE BLOOD PREVENTING
HEARING NEEDS IN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO SINCERELY
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM FOR
HIS PERSEVERANCE AND
PERSISTENCE ON THIS ISSUE. I
KNOW IT HAS BEEN CHALLENGING.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR CAN'T ALLOW
SKI AND I AM A VETERINARIAN
LICENSE IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CLINICAL DIRECTOR AND OWNER AT
INSIGHT THAT IN A WELLNESS
CENTER. IT'S MALL ANIMAL
HOSPITAL IN BOULDER RADO HILLS
PROVIDING PRIMARY CARE AND
TWENTY FOUR HOUR EMERGENCY CARE.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE EIGHT
VETERINARIANS INCLUDING A FULL
TIME BOARDED CRITICAL US APART
TIME INTERNIST AND CONTRACTED
CARDIOLOGISTS AND SURGEONS.
PRIOR TO OPENING OUR NEW
HOSPITAL LAST YEAR WE ON TO
BANFIELD HOSPITALS DAYTIME
GENERAL PRACTICES IN THOSE
HOSPITALS ARE NEED FOR BLOOD
WAS VERY RARE AND IF WE DID
NEED IT WE WOULD USUALLY
COLLECTED FROM ONE OF OUR STAFF
AT. WHO WAS MORE CRITICAL WILL
BE REFERRED TO AN EMERGENCY
HOSPITAL. NOW IS AN EMERGENCY
HOSPITAL IS A WHOLE NEW
BALLGAME. WE NEVER KNOW WHEN WE
WILL NEED BLOOD OR BLOOD
PRODUCTS BUT THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN WE HAVE MULTIPLE PETS IN
NEED OFTEN REQUIRING MULTIPLE
UNITS THAT WE HAD ONE MASS
REMOVAL SURGERY RECENTLY THAT
ENDED UP BEING FOUR UNITS OF
WHOLE BLOOD FOR PACKED RBCS.
AND FOUR UNITS OF CLASS MY-
AFTER USING OUR IN HOUSE LAST
NIGHT IN YOUR HEAD A BLOOD CLOT
FROM ATTACK. DOT WE BORROWED
AND PLASMA THREE OTHER BIRDS
HOUSE. INCLUDING ONE ALL THE
WAY OUT FAIRFIELD. EFFECTIVELY
WIPING OUT THE BLOOD SUPPLY IN
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA.
THIS FORCES US TO MAKE HARD
CHOICES BETWEEN WHICH PATIENTS
WILL BE G. BLOOD PRODUCTS.
THERE SIMPLY IS NOT ENOUGH
BLOOD TO THE PATIENTS WHO NEED
IT. WELL I UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN FOR THE
DOG CONFINED TO THE TOO CLOSE
COUNTY BLOOD BANKS. MY BIGGER
CONCERNS RELATED BE AN ADEQUATE
SUPPLY OF BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS FOR PATIENTS. THE TWO
COMPANIES SIMPLY CANNOT SUPPLY
THE NEEDS OF CRITICALLY ILL AND
INJURED PETS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS WHY I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO WHICH WILL
ALLOW VETERINARIANS TO
ESTABLISH COMMUNITY BASED BLOOD
BANK AND DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
THE BLOOD AVAILABLE TO OUR
PATIENTS. IN ADDITION IT WILL
ALLOW US TO IMPORT THESE
PRODUCTS FROM OUT OF STATE AS
LONG AS THEY MEET OUR SAFETY
STANDARDS. WE ALSO NEED TO BE
ASSURED THAT BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS COMING FROM ALL THESE
SOURCES REMAIN SAFE. SO IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT SURPRISING
GUIDELINES THE STAB MR SURE NOT
ONLY AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY IT ALSO
IS A SUPPLY. I TRULY HOPE THAT
NONE OF YOUR PET AND WE NEED
THE TRANSFUSION. BUT IF THEY
WOULD WHAT DO YOU WANT TO NOTE
THAT THERE'S ONE AVAILABLE
TURNOUT. RESULT HI AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU MMHM. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
NEXT WITH THIS. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR JEAN
BERGER AND I'M A LICENSED
CALIFORNIA THAT MARION AND THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF RESCUE
AND WELFARE FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA. THROUGH UC
DAVIS I AM BOARD CERTIFIED WITH
BOTH THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF IT
NAY BEHAVIORIST AND THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF ANIMAL
WELFARE. IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
I HAVE OVERSEEING ALL ASPECTS
OF CLINICAL BEHAVIOR AND
WELFARE PROGRAMS AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA. I'M HERE TODAY
TO URGE YOU TO VOTE I AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO TO MODERNIZE
CALIFORNIA'S ANIMAL BLOOD
BANKING INDUSTRY. VETERINARIANS
AND THE PUBLIC ON CREE SINGLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WELFARE
STATUS STATUS OF ANIMALS IN
SOCIETY. THESE CHANGES HAVE
IMPACTED MOST AREAS OF
VETERINARY PRACTICE INCLUDING
THE K. NINE BLOCK BANKING
INDUSTRY. THE CURRENT SITUATION
IN CALIFORNIA IS EGREGIOUSLY ON
BALANCE BLOOD DONORS DOGS ARE
KEPT CONFINED FOR MONTHS OR
YEARS IN APPALLING CONDITIONS.
FORTUNATELY IN A MOVE THAT
RECOGNIZES THE INTRINSIC NEEDS
OF THESE DOGS MANY BLOOD BANKS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
TRANSITIONED FROM CLOSE COLONY
PROGRAMS TO COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS THAT COLLECT BLOOD
FROM PRE SCREENED HEALTHY
FAMILY PET. WITH ESTABLISHED
AND SUCCESSFUL PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE. CALIFORNIA VETERINARIANS
PROCESS THE NECESSARY EDUCATION
AND SKILLS TO MODERNIZE THIS
INDUSTRY IN WAYS THAT ARE
PRACTICAL SAFE AND HUMANE. WE
ARE EAGER TO WORK TOGETHER AS A
PROFESSION TO MAKE COMMUNITY
BROUGHT BLOOD BANKS THE
STANDARD OF CARE. THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA ALREADY HAVE TO
SPACE AND CAPACITY TO COLLECT
BLOOD. CALIFORNIA STATE LAW
MUST FIRST LAY OUT THE
FRAMEWORK THAT BALANCES THE
INTERESTS AND WELL BEING OF
DONOR ANIMALS RECIPIENT ANIMALS
AND VETERINARIANS WHO NEED
ACCESS TO HEALTHY BLOOD SUPPLY.
I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT WE CAN
TRANSITION THE REMAINING CLOSE
COLONY BLOOD BANKS TO COMMUNITY
MODEL. COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS
ARE STATE. AT THE- PRACTICAL
AND BENEFICIAL TO THE DONOR
RECIPIENT AND THEIR OWNERS I
URGE YOU TO VOTE I ON AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
WE HAVE- DR JEAN DODDS OF
PRESIDENT OF HAM- PAT AND-
CHARLES BERMAN GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR HIM A PET SO. THOSE
WITNESSES ARE- READY. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO YES PROVIDE OKAY
FANTASTIC. THIS IS STUTTERING
DOGS I'M THE DIRECTOR AND
CREATOR OF HIM OKAY I'M
NONPROFIT ANIMAL BLOOD BANK IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- THANK YOU
CHERRY WAS ON THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING US TO SPEAK- ABOUT
THIS BILL. I MUST TELL YOU THAT
I AM TOTALLY IN FAVOR OF THE
CONCEPT OF COMMUNITY BLOOD
BANKS BECAUSE WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH THE SHORTAGE OF BLOOD
SUPPLY FOR PETS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE
HOWEVER. I INVITE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROOM AND ANYBODY ELSE
INCLUDING THE TWO PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS TO COME AND VISIT OUR
FACILITY BECAUSE I AM TOTALLY
AGHAST THAT ANYBODY WOULD SAY
THE CONDITIONS WE HAVE ARE
APPALLING. WITHOUT SIDE LET ME
TELL YOU THAT I HAVE BEEN FORTY
YEARS AS AN EXPERT IN
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE IN BOTH
HUMAN. AND ANIMAL BUT MAKING I
RAN A REGULATED THE STATE OF
NEW YORK'S BLOOD SUPPLY. AT THE
TIME OF THE AIDS CRISIS I WAS
WELL AWARE AT THAT TIME THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE SIMILAR BLOOD
BANKS FOR ANIMALS THAT TOOK
INTO CONSIDERATION. THE HEALTH.
AND THE WELFARE NOT ONLY OF THE
DONORS BUT ALSO OF THE
RECIPIENTS. IN ADDITION TO OUR
WRITTEN. TESTIMONY ABOUT AB ONE
TWO EIGHT TWO- WHERE WE NEED TO
HAVE ANIMALS OF A PARTICULAR
SIZE A PARTICULAR- AGE AND ALSO
TRACTABLE. COMMUNITY DONORS
OKAY THAT'S CLEAR. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH THE INFECTIOUS DISEASE.
POTENTIAL OF THESE COMMUNITY
DONORS. SO EVEN THOUGH THESE
ANIMALS MAY BE HEALTHY AND MAY
BE SCREENED OCCASIONALLY FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES THAT COULD
BE TRANSMITTED BY BLOOD. THEY
NEED TO BE TESTED THE BLOOD
FROM THOSE ANIMALS NEEDS TO BE
TESTED EVERY TIME THEY PROVIDE
A DONATION WHETHER IT BE TWO
THREE OR FOUR TIMES A YEAR.
THAT'S BECAUSE HEALTHY ANIMALS
CAN CARRY INFECTIOUS VIRUSES
FOR EXAMPLE. DEBILITATED OR ILL
PATIENT COULD SUCCUMB TO SHOULD
THEY BE TRANSMITTED INCLUDING
THINGS LIKE EVEN HEARTWORM
DISEASE. SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BLOOD IS CHECKED
THAT THE DON'T RESPECT. THEY
DON'T HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T PARTICIPATE IN SUFFERING
AND EVEN GOD FORBID DEATH OF A
EAST FELLOW RECIPIENTS-
SECONDLY IN ORDER TO DEVELOP
THE STANDARDS FOR THE PROPOSED-
AB ONE TWO EIGHT TWO-
REGULATIONS WE NEED TO HAVE AN
ADVISORY GROUP. OF EXPERTS THAT
COULD BE FORMED AND BE
AVAILABLE TO SET THE STANDARDS
OF HOW WE WOULD DO THIS
EFFECTIVELY AND SAFELY. WE NEED
TO HAVE THIS ADVISORY BOARD
AVAILABLE NOW AND TO BE
CONTINUING AS AN ENTITY TO HELP
US IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE EFFECT OF THESE
REGULATIONS OR STANDARDS AS
THEY ARE DEVELOPED SHOULD BE
MONITORED INFO I REQUEST I'M
I'M AVAILABLE SHOULD ANYBODY
NEED MY HELP IN THIS REGARD SO
I REQUEST THAT BEFORE WE ACCEPT
AB ONE TWO EIGHT TWO IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. THAT WE OPPOSE IT
UNTIL THESE ISSUES ARE
CONSIDERED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. I AM I AM
THE NEXT THAT. WITNESS MY NAME
IS CHARLES BERMAN I'M THE
GENERAL COUNSEL OF HIM A BIT.
I'VE BEEN THE GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR HIM A BIT FOR THIRTY FIVE
YES- I WANT TO STATE. AND THANK
YOU AS WELL AS THE CHAIR RIVAS
AND YOUR COMMITTEE FOR HEARING
US OUT ON THIS ISSUE. I THINK
MOST IMPORTANTLY WANT THIS
COMMITTEE NEEDS TO KNOW IT IN
THE OPERATION OF HIM UP AT FOUR
THIRTY FIVE YES THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN A SINGLE COMPLAINT. LODGED
AGAINST THE MEDICAL QUALITY OF
THE BLOOD PRODUCED BY HUMAN AT.
SO WHY HIM A PATH AND I-
APPROVE. BECAUSE OF COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANK. WE THAT IT'S
IMPLEMENTATION AS PROPOSED IN
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO IS SERIOUSLY
LACKING IN THAT ANALYSIS AND
ITS CONSEQUENCES. THE BELL AT
SET UP NOW IS RIPE FOR
LITIGATION AND LIABILITY NOT
ONLY TO THE OFFICE BUT TO THE
STATE TO THE DONUTS TO THE VET
TO THE RECIPIENTS WHO WILL BE
GETTING THIS PLOT IF LEAD
MEDICAL REQUIREMENTS OF THE
DONUT THAT IS NOT PROPERLY
CARED FOR AS HAS BEEN ADDRESS
BY DOCTOR DR. THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE RIPE FOR LITIGATION ALL
OVER THE MAP AND THEY'RE THE
KIND OF LITIGATION THAT COULD
RESULT IS FOR PAIN SUFFERING
AND DEATH TO THE RECIPIENT
ANIMAL WE NEED. NOT REALLY HAVE
TO TALK MUCH ABOUT THE
LITIGATION CENTRIC. ASPECT OF
OXIDE. I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT HE MIGHT PET HAS INVITED
THE AUTHOR AND HE STOPPED AND A
CO AUTHOR SENATOR WILL COME TO
HIM A BIT UNANNOUNCED AT ANY
TIME. IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
THAT THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO
PASS THIS BILL NOT ONCE. DID
ANYONE DARING TO EVEN RESPOND
TO OUR INVITE TO COME TO SEE IN
MY BED AND SEE THE CONDITIONS
UNDER WHICH THEY- THAT BANKERS
OPERATE. WE CAN TELL YOU THAT
THE- OKAY MEDITATION THE- THE
MEDICAL BOARD HAS. INSPECTED
HIM A PET SEVERAL TIMES
UNANNOUNCED AND IT NEVER EVER
FOUND A FULL IN THE OPERATION
OF HIM OF THAT SO TO BE TALKING
ABOUT CONDITIONS THAT HE MY PAD
WHICH ARE UNTRUE REALLY IS.
IT'S SAD SAD COMMENTARY ON THE
POSITION PUT FORWARD BY THIS
PROBLEM. SO HAVING SAID THAT
THE FACT THAT THIS BILL IS
BEING PRESENTED NOW FOR THE
THIRD YEAR RUNNING DOESN'T MEAN
TO SAY SHOULD POTS IF IN FACT
THE DISTRAUGHT. WE FORESEE THAT
THIS BOTH FRANKLY IS A ROAD TO
DISASTER. PAVED WITH GOOD
INTENTIONS. AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL IN ITS STATE AND OFF THIS
COMMITTEE TO REFERRED BACK FOR
LEGAL ANALYSIS AND THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT THAT HAPPENED
IF IS BOTH PARTIES IN ITS
CURRENT STATE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME WILL OPEN
IT UP FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT-
IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
THAT WOULD. LIKE TO MAKE
COMMENTS C. NONE WE WILL- GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATED WE
HAVECALLERS IN THE QUEUE- FOR
SOME PUBLIC COMMENT. YES WE DO
NINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL OUR
AND I'M THE CFO FOR SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND FOR
OTHERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IT IS ONE ZERO FOUR TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE MAKOTO LIKE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS NICHOLAS SACKETT
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION. I AM- REPRESENTING
SKILL I'M ALSO REPRESENTING-
TODAY PEOPLE FOR THE ETHICAL
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS. LOS
ANGELES DAMS FOR THE-
PROTECTION OF ANIMALS AND THE
HUMANE SOCIETY VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AUTHOR
OF MR BLOOM THIS IS MATT
ROBINSON WE SHOW YOUR INTO
SHELTERS LAGGED ON BEHALF OF
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES IN SUPPORT AND I
WAS ALSO ASKED TO CONVEY THE
SUPPORT OF CAL ANIMALS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE RIGHT BOTH.
FINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JEFFREY LEE **** ON
BEHALF OF ANIMAL BLOOD BANK-
THE OTHER BLOOD BANK LICENSED
IN CALIFORNIA TO PRODUCE BLOOD.
WHITE THE PROPONENTS AND OUR
FELLOW BLOOD BANK WE SHARE THE
GOAL OF OPENING UP THE MARKET
TO COMMUNITY BLOOD FOR AS LONG
AS THERE HAVE BEEN BLOOD BANKS
THE DEMAND FOR BLOOD HAS
EXCEEDED THE SUPPLY- THAT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE COLONY
BLOOD BANK- MODEL IN FACT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
QUALITY AND MOST ABUNDANT
SUPPLY OF BLOOD ANYWHERE ON THE
PLANET. AND IT'S BECAUSE OF-
THE LICENSING AND REGULATIONS
THAT EXIST NONETHELESS WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOAL OF THE
BILL WE DO HAVE TWO CONCERNS
THAT I WANTED TO TOUCH ON THEIR
BOTH RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
FIRST ONE HAS TO DO WITH THE
TRIGGER WHEN YOU WOULD BEGIN TO
WIND DOWN PROCESS OF COLONY
BASED PRODUCTION- AS THE BILL
IS. DRAFTED BAPTIST NUMBER SO
WHETHER IT BE ONE TEN OR A
HUNDRED YEARS FROM NOW- IF
COMMUNITY BLOOD HITS THAT
TRIGGER AMOUNT- WHICH WOULD AT
THAT POINT ONLY BE HALF OF THE
TOTAL BLOOD IN THE MARKET. THE
TRIGGER LANGUAGE WOULD HAVE
QUALITY BASED PRODUCTION AND
TWELVE MONTHS LATER- THAT'S A
RECIPE FOR DISASTER WE THINK
THAT THE TRIGGER AMOUNT NEEDS
TO BE A DYNAMIC NUMBER- BASED
ON A ROLLING AVERAGE OF PRIOR
YEARS. AND WE ALSO THINK THAT
ONCE THE TRIGGER IS PULLED THAT
THE RAMP DOWN NEEDS TO BE
GRADUAL AND NOT- MEDIA. SO THAT
THERE'S A CHANCE FOR COMMUNITY
BLOOD PRODUCTION TO GROW TO
REPLACE THE REDUCTION. THE
OTHER ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH THE
STANDARDS FOR PRODUCING FAKE
BLOOD AND- WE SEE NO REASON TO
REFERENCE AB H. TM- WE HAVE
AGREED TO THE EXISTING
CONSENSUS STATEMENT BUT THE
FACT IS IF YOU'RE FINDING A
POSITION THAT THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD TO ESTABLISH BEST
PRACTICES. THAT PERSON CAN LOOK
AT WHATEVER'S AVAILABLE AND
MAKE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO
BEST PRACTICES THE STATE OUGHT
NOT TO BE DELEGATING AUTHORITY
OVER- BLOOD BANKING PRACTICES
TO THESE PRIVATE ENTITIES
PARTICULARLY NOT AB H. TìM.
WHICH IS A FINE ORGANIZATION
BUT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
STANDARD SETTING- AND IS VERY
SMALL. OKAY WELL LET YOU MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL BE YOUR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO- EMAIL- HI
COMMITTEE WE'D BE HAPPY TO-
EXCEPT THOSE COMMENTS AS WELL.
OPERATOR THANK YOU. YES WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING- THIS IS SHANNON KEITH
ON BEHALF OF BEAGLE FREEDOM
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT. NINE SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MELANIE SADEK I'M CALLING O
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT NEARLY ALL PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ANIMAL SHELTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. HELLO CODE
ON LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MNICA
ENGEBRETSON WITH CRUELTY FREE
INTERNATIONAL IN SUPPORT.
CAROLINE NUMBER SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
FINALLY THE YEAR GOES AND I AM
FROM WHITTIER CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DANNY MONTALCINO I AM
FROM BURBANK CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE. HI THIS
IS JUDY MAN CREW SO FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL COMPASSION
IN LEGISLATION WE HAVE BEEN THE
SPONSOR WORKING WITH SENATOR
WILK ON- THIS ISSUE FOR OVER A
COUPLE YEARS AND WE THANK
CENTER WILK AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM- FOR GIVING IT ONE LAST
GO WE GOT IT ALL THE WAY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. AND THIS BILL
IS ANSWERING A CREDO MESSAGE SO
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. AND TO BE JUST ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT ONE. WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MERRY PRIOR IN
ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT TWELVE EIGHTY TWO.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MA'AM OPERATOR AND WITH
THAT I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS PRESSURE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER BLOOM-
THAT I KNOW WE'VE BEEN DEBATING
THIS ONE FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN
YOUR EFFORTS ON IT- THE A TRUST
WITH- YOUR NEGOTIATIONS MOVE
FORWARD. YOU'RE THE WORKING ON.
I TO GETTING SOME BETTER
UNDERSTANDING FOR THIS TRIGGER
MECHANISM THAT'S- CONCERN. IS
THAT- CAN I GET A COMMITMENT
FROM YOU THAT YOU EXACTLY
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT REMAINS
UNDER DISCUSSION AND- I'LL
COMMIT TO- THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT ALONG WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO- SEE WHAT
RESOLUTION WE CAN COME UP WITH
THE WITH YOUR COMMITMENT TO DO
THAT ALL LIVE HAPPILY COME ON
AS A CO AUTHOR WITH YOU. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. AS LONG
AS IT'S AN ACCURATE DEPICTION
OF WHAT'S TRANSPIRED HERE THAT
THERE WAS A PREVIOUS VERSIONS
THIS BILL THAT WENT FURTHER
INTO MARCH IS BANNING THE
PRACTICE IS THAT RIGHT NOW WAS
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR OR
UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY. I
DON'T WANT TO MISREPRESENT THE
DETAILS OF THAT BILL- BUT I
OKAY WELL THAT I BELIEVE THE
VERSION THAT WENT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK DID AND THE
GOVERNOR IN HIS VETO MESSAGE
SUPPORTED THE INTENTION OF THAT
BILL- WHILE THE DOING IT. SO I
GUESS WHAT OCCURS TO ME IS THAT
THE FINAL ISSUE HERE THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT THERE IS
FACILITIES- WE HAVE SOME
WITNESSES HERE TODAY SUGGESTING
THAT THESE FACILITIES ARE- LESS
THAN APPROPRIATE OR UNSAFE FOR.
OR HAVE SOME POOR TREATMENT. OF
THE ANIMALS IN THOSE
FACILITIES. I DON'T HAVE FIRST
HAND KNOWLEDGE. THAT THAT'S
TRUE OR NOT TRUE- BUT THAT'S
CERTAINLY THE ASSERTION. CALL
PLEASE HANG UP AND TRY AGAIN.
MISTER BLOOM BETTER WITH. THAT
WAS DIRECTED AT YOU SIR SHOULD.
AND THE- I GUESS CHRISTMAS WHAT
DOES MAKE SENSE TO ME IS IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO THESE KIND OF
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS OPERATED
BY YOUR LOCAL VETERINARIANS.
WHICH DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A
REASONABLE SOLUTION THEN MOVING
FORWARD WITH AUTHORIZING THAT
ACTIVITY AND ALLOWING THOSE
COMMITTEE BLOOD TO. OCCUR AND
THEN HOPEFULLY GROW RIGHT
BECAUSE I AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THE ONE OF THE REASONS THE
GOVERNOR VETOED THE ORIGINAL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS THAT
THERE'S LEGITIMATE CONCERN THAT
IF WE MOVED TO COMMITTEE BLOOD
BANKS WITHOUT THESE FACILITIES
THAT THERE MIGHT BE. A SHORTAGE
OF SUPPLY- I THINK THAT'S
EVERYONE'S CONCERN OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T WANT TO CREATE A SHORTAGE
OF BLOOD AND THAT'S WHY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS BROUGHT
UP THE ISSUE OF WHAT THE-
TRIGGERS WOULD BE AND THAT IS
ISSUE IS. CONTINUING TO BE
UNDER DISCUSSION OF LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL AND OUT ITALY WILL BE
MODIFIED AND- HOPEFULLY IN
KEEPING WITH A CONSENSUS THAT
CAN BE. REACHED ON- WHAT ARE
THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH
WE CAN TRANSITION OUT OF THE-
CURRENT LARGELY CLOSE TO
QUALITY SYSTEM. TO THE
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANK A MODEL.
WHY IS THAT NO GETS RIGHT TO
THE HEART OF THE ISSUE FOR ME
IS I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE HAVE INCLUDED IN THIS
VERSION OF THE BILL- TRIGGERS
AND- AUTHORIZATION. TO SHUT
DOWN THESE FACILITIES RATHER
THAN APPROACHING THE PROBLEM
FROM LET'S CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKS. LET'S TAKE THE
PROPER STEPS TO- YOU KNOW GET
PUBLICITY AND SUPPORT TO THOSE
EFFORTS IN THE HOPES THAT
PEOPLE WILL UTILIZE THEM. AND
THAT THOSE WILL BECOME SELF
SUSTAINING WON'T NEED THESE
OTHER SELLERS THAT'LL MAKE
SENSE. THEN IN A SUBSEQUENT
SESSION IF WE WANT TO COME BACK
AND LOOK AT PHASING OUT THOSE
FACILITIES THAT SEEMS LIKE AN
APPROPRIATE QUESTION AT THAT
TIME. BUT TO DO IT HERE IN THE
WAY- WERE KIND OF POINTING. OUT
TO THE AGENCIES AND- AND
SENDING ALL THIS WITHOUT HAVING
ALL THE INFORMATION IN FRONT OF
US BECAUSE LIKE YOU KNOW YOU
HADN'T HAVE INCLUDING YOUR BILL
COLLECTION OF QUITE A BIT OF
INFORMATION THAT SEEMS
APPROPRIATE AND HELPFUL- SO I
GUESS. WHAT I'M DRIVING AT HERE
IS IF YOU WERE TO REMOVE THE-
WHAT WHAT WHAT I WOULD DESCRIBE
THE PREMATURE- ELIMINATION OF
THESE FACILITIES FROM THE BILL
AND JUST FOCUS ON THE COMMITTEE
BLOOD BANKS AND THE- REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WHICH MAKE A TON
OF SENSE. I FEEL LIKE I COULD
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT WITH THE
OTHER PROVISION IN THERE- IT
LEAVES ME WITH SOME CONCERN-
REGARDING THE AVAILABILITY
BLOOD SUPPLY AND YOU KNOW IT.
REMINDS ME OF WHAT CENTER RIGHT
RIGHT USED TO SAY WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A BILL THE FIRST
QUESTION IS THERE A PROBLEM.
WELL I WOULD ARGUE MAYBE MAYBE
THERE'S A PROBLEM HERE I'M NOT
TOTALLY CONVINCED. DOES THIS
LEGISLATION IN FRONT OF US
OFFER A SOLUTION. I THINK
PARTIALLY IT OFFERS A SOLUTION
CERTAINLY SETS SOME OF THE
PIECES IN PLACE AND THEN THE
THIRD AND FINAL QUESTION IS A
SOLUTION WORSE THAN THE
ORIGINAL PROBLEM. AND THE
JURY'S OUT ON THAT IF WE'RE
GOING TO INCLUDE- THIS
PROVISION. TO DISCONTINUE THESE
FACILITIES- PREMATURELY- SO
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO TAKE AN
AMENDMENT TO. TAKE THAT OUT-
WORK ON THESE OTHER PIECES NO
WE WOULD NOT AND TO- THE REASON
FOR THAT IS THAT- THE BILL IS
FOCUSED ON TWO GOALS- ONE GOAL
IS TO SHIFT TO A MORE HUMANE-
BLOOD. DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT TO
OF- AT THAT IS THE COMMUNITY
BLOOD DONOR MODEL- AT THE SAME
TIME IT RECOGNIZES THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THE CLOSE
QUALITY MODEL- IS. A FAR LESS
THAN IDEAL FOR THE ANIMALS WHO
WERE INVOLVED AND SO THE
IMPORTANCE OF SHIFTING OUT OF
THAT MODEL UNDER THE PROPER
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THAT'S WHY
THERE IS DETAIL IN THE BILL
THAT. LAYS OUT WHAT THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD BE AND
THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING GUN-
IMPROVING THE LANGUAGE- THAT
THE TRIGGER LANGUAGE THAT'S WHY
THAT PART OF THE BILLS IN THERE
BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT AND THE
BILL RECOGNIZES IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ADDRESS BOTH OF THESE GOALS
NOT JUST ONE IF WE- WEEK. DO
KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN PRIOR
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL- THAT
WERE NOT SUCCESSFUL THAT- THAT
DID SPLIT OFF THESE ISSUES- BUT
BY SPLITTING OFF THE ISSUE
YOU'RE REALLY DELAYING- AN
ISSUE REGARDING THE WELL BEING
AND THE HEALTH. OF FOLK OF
THESE ANIMALS. IN THE CLOSE
CALL IN THE SYSTEM I UNDERSTAND
THERE WAS TESTIMONY THAT
THERE'S NO PROBLEM THERE BUT
THERE'S NO DENYING THE FACT
THAT THE CLOSE CALL IN THE
SYSTEM. REQUIRES DOGS TO BE
KEPT IN CONFINEMENT- ON
PREMISES THAT'S THE WAY THE
SYSTEM WORKS AND WE WANT TO
MOVE AWAY FROM THAT MODEL AT
THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME AND
NOT PUT THAT OFF TO SOME-
DISTANT DATE. IN THE FUTURE
THAT'S ON CERTAIN. SHE THAT
INFORMATION HAVE VISIT THE CALL
TO. ARE AND THE PAPERS THAT I
HAVE NOT YOU HAVE NOT. BUT WE
KNOW WHAT THE FACT YOU KNOW
THERE THERE IS DISAGREEMENT
OVER. WHETHER DOGS ARE TREATED
HUMANELY ARE NOT ON PROMISES
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THAT SYSTEM
AND IS IRREFUTABLE IS THAT DOGS
ARE KEPT IN CAPTIVITY FOR YEARS
ON END. THAT'S THE PART OF THE
SYSTEM THAT IS MOST CRUCIAL TO
ADD. I'M NOT SURE WERE ARE. ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT- IN AGREEMENT
THERE BUT- IF YOU'RE NOT
WILLING TO TAKE THE MEMBER I
DON'T THINK I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING- THE BILL THIS
AFTERNOON I APPRECIATE- AND
HAVE EVERY BIT OF FAITH AND
TRUST IN YOU AS A COLLEAGUE AND
KNOW THAT YOU DO GOOD WORK BUT
THE- UNFORTUNATE BAD HABIT THIS
INSTITUTION. HAS DEVELOPED IN
RECENT YEARS AS WE- OPERATE A
LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH LIKE A BILL
FACTORY JUST MOVE BILLS ALONG
ONE WE'VE IDENTIFIED ISSUES AND
WE DON'T RESOLVE THEM WHEN
THEY'RE IN FRONT OF US I AM IN
SOME CASES THAT'S FOR REASONS
YOU KNOW SOME COMMITTEES AT
DIFFERENT MAKE UPS ON THE FLOOR
AND HEN WE GET INTO.
DISAGREEMENTS IDEOLOGICALLY
SOMETIMES IT'S TO YOUR
ADVANTAGE TO MOVE IT TO THE
NEXT STEP- RATHER THAN FACE THE
MUSIC IN A PARTICULAR COMMITTEE
SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
LOBBYIST FOR THE BILL TODAY
BUT- APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWERS
THANK YOU AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S IN PLAY HERE.
ASSEMBLY ONE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- GERMAN RIVAS OF THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLOOMY YOU KNOW
I'VE HAD ISSUES WITH THE
PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF YOUR BILL
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERNED WITH-
SUPPLY I THINK THIS BILL WENT
MUCH FURTHER IN ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SUPPLIES THERE BUT I'M
I HEARD ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
TALK ABOUT THE TRIGGER IS THAT
ONE HALF THE SUPPLY. IS
FURNISHED BY THESE COMMUNITY-
BANKS THEN THE PHASE THAT WOULD
START AND I YOU KNOW I'M JUST
NOT REALLY CLEAR ON WHAT THE
ACTUAL TRIGGER IS IT LIKE THAT
WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT OF A
PREMATURE TRICK SO I THINK
THAT'S A REFERENCE TO- THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THE BILL
CURRENTLY THERE ARE AMENDMENTS
THAT- WE WILL BE TAKING AND
THERE ARE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
THAT WILL TAKE PLACE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WAS SAID
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS THIS
QUESTION AND- OF MY COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
ISSUE. AT THAT PROCESS I THINK
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY AND HOPEFULLY WE WILL SEE
SOME OF- GOOD WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT IN A POSITION THAT WE
HAVE A FEW YEARS DOWN THE ROAD
A- BLOOD SHORTAGE FOR THESE
STUFF BUT NERI THANK YOU I
DON'T THINK THAT- ISN'T ANY
BUDDIES. BEST INTEREST.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GET FREE. THANK
YOU MISTER BLOOM- I JUST WANT
TO ASK YOU JUST TO CONSIDER THE
TWO ISSUES THAT CAME UP BY THE
OPPOSITION THE TRIGGER. AND HOW
THAT'LL WORK. AND CONSIDER THE
BILL'S ROLE THE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICAN MYTHOLOGY TRANSFUSION
MEDICINE JUST LIKE YOU TO HAVE
MORE CONVERSATION ON THAT- AND
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE WORKING HARD
ON THIS AND THAT YOU REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. ANIMALS
HAVE GOOD HEALTHY BLOOD THAT
THERE IF THERE'S A TRANSFUSION-
SO WITH THAT- I APPRECIATE YOU
WOULD CONSIDER THOSE ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP TODAY. AND
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL DO THAT.
K. ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION WITH THAT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS LEGISLATION THIS ISSUE- IN
PARTICULAR- MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I'M SORRY
I HAVE TO GET A MOTION AND A WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM MISTER
MATHIS OF I SHOULD MATHIS ARE
SECOND. SECOND SECOND BY
SOMEONE NUMBER JONES SAWYER IF
YOU PLEASE CALL HOME INSPECTOR
THANK YOU. ON ITEM TWO AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TO BLOOM- MOTION
IS DUE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS HI. RIVAS
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I'D
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING LARA FOUR I AGREE NO
GRAY NO- ONE. IRWIN AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE
LEVINE IDEA PUT OFF BY THE
APPROVED LAW I WOULD. WE HAVE
EIGHT VOTE SIX EIGHT OKAY I
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOWN
A BILL IS OUT AND THEN IF WE
CAN- BECAUSE WE DO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WHO JOINED
THE HEARING CAN WE GO BACK AND
DO SOME ADD ONS FOR I BELIEVE
IS A CONTENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I'D GREAT GRAY I
IRWIN. IRWIN IDEA PUT OFF BY
THE APPROVED LAW I WOULD. THE
LAST COUNT. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY. ONE YEAH IF YEAH IF
THERE ARE. ON ITEM WHAT A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT US ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA MOTION
WAS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROACH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
OH FIVE NUMBER ALL BUT I'LL
GREAT I THOUGHT THE BILL HAS
ELEVEN VOTE. WE'RE GOOD OKAY SO
WE WILL MOVE THE LAST ITEM ON
THE AGENDA FILE TIED HIM THREE.
IN THE BILL EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
OUR VERY OWN MISTER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIVING THANK YOU SECOND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER-
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- GOOD MORNING
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT WOULD
ALLOW THE ON SITE MOBILE
SLAUGHTERING OF SHEEP GOATS AND
SWINE BY MOBILE SLAUGHTER
OPERATOR. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN AUTHORIZED
THIS- PROCESSING OF CATTLE- FOR
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING PURCHASE
ANIMAL FOR THEIR OWN
CONSUMPTION THIS BILL EXTENDS
THAT RESPECT LAST FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU SEVEN NUMBER LEVINE
DO HAVE- WHEN THIS IS SUPPORT-
ROBERT SPIEGEL OF CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU. OPERATOR IS A
WITNESS READY TO- GO. BUT WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR MR SPIEGEL
THERE THERE HAS BEEN TESTIMONY-
INTRODUCED BY MARCIA BETTER
KNOWLEDGE OF MARC BERMAN ON A
RANCH THAT WAS DISSEMINATED
ALONG WITH TODAY'S AGENDA- FOR
YOU TO. I BELIEVE IT IS IN THE
PACKAGE YEAH I THINK YOU. THIS
IS BIGELOW YOU ON THE LINE.
READ IT HERE SIR YES WE CAN.
PERFECT GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
ROBERT SIEGEL FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEES TO SPONSORED EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO EXTEND OUR APPRECIATION
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE FOR
GRANTED AGAIN CARRY THIS BILL
FORWARD AND TO OUR LIVESTOCK
NUMBERS IN MARIN COUNTY FOR
THEIR ASSISTANCE IN MAKING
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT THEY
ARE BETTER BILL. AS PROPOSED TO
BE AMENDED EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT WOULD EXPAND THE ABILITY
OF SMALL SCALE RANCHERS TO
UTILIZE WHAT'S CALLED A
REGISTERED MOBILE FOUR OPERATOR
TO CONDUCT ON FARM SLAUGHTER
PERSONAL RUMINANTS LIKE GOATS
SHEEP AND SWINE UNFORTUNATELY
UNDER EXISTING LAW PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS THE
FOR WILL BE SET THE EXISTING
EXCLUSION IS LIMITED TO JUST BE
CATTLE. EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT WOULD ALLOW A RANCHER TO
SELL LIVE ANIMAL DIRECTLY TO A
CONSUMER FOR THE CONSUMER SOME
PERSONAL USE THAT AUTHORIZES AN
MSO TO SAFELY AND HUMANELY
SLAUGHTERED THE ANIMAL AND A
PRIVATE BRANCH IN ACCORDANCE
WITH ALL LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THIS WOULD
MEAN THAT THE ANIMAL DOESN'T
NEED TO BE TRANSPORTED TO A
BRICK AND MORTAR FACILITY AND
THEREBY REDUCES THE COST TO
TRANSPORT HARVESTING PROCESSING
WHILE ALSO MINIMIZING
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS IN
SCHEDULING. THIS LIMITED OPTION
THOUGH ALSO HAS VARIOUS ANIMAL
HEALTH BENEFITS AS THE ANIMALS
NEVER REQUIRED TO LEAVE THE
RANCH WE DON'T ALSO DON'T HAVE
TO ADD THE STRUCTURE TRANSPORT
AND POTENTIAL RISK OF INJURY TO
THE ANIMAL BY EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT IS
OUT CAPS THE NUMBER OF ANIMALS
THAT CAN BE SOLD REQUIRES THE
RANCHER NSO AND CUSTOM ENGINE
PROCESSOR TO MAINTAIN SPECIFIED
RECORDS FOR TWO YEARS IT
REQUIRES THE RECORD TO BE
PRESENTED TO CDFA FOR
INSPECTION. IT FOR THE REQUIRES
THE MSO TO BE REGISTERED THE
CDFA AND SPECIFICALLY FORBIDS
ANY COTTON WRAP MEAT PRODUCTS
FOR COMMERCIAL SALE LAST WEEK
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT NEEDS
A NEW AND GROWIG CONSUMER
PREFERENCE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S TO HELP LOCAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH SUSTAINABLE
PRODUCERS TO KNOW THE PRODUCERS
ON FARM PRACTICES AND ANIMAL
HUSBANDRY PROTOCOLS AND
SUPPORTS LOCAL BUSINESS. THE
BILL DEVELOPING ENCOURAGE YOU
SPEAK NEW NEW BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL SCALE
AGRICULTURE AND MEETS THE
DYNAMICALLY CHANGING FOOD
PREFERENCES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS SO LET'S CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT PRODUCERS AND
CONSUMERS. LOOKING FOR SAFE AND
SUSTAINED BOTH. AND LOCALLY RAY
LIVES WITH THAT. ORDER IF WE
CAN. RESPECTFUL ASK YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
SPIEGEL- THERE IS NO OP. ON
FILE AT THIS TIME. UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU IN THE ROOM
WITH TO MAKE. SAY NONE TAKE IT
TO THE- LINE- OPERATOR. THERE
SOME CALLERS IN THE QUEUE FOR
COMMENTS. IN LATE IN GERMAN WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTARY AB EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AT THE MOMENT WE DO HAVE TO IN
OUR QUEUE. I WILL START WITH
NUMBER SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DAVE RENTON COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS WE SUPPORT.
NEXT WILL BE GONNA TO NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR- NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JUSTIN ROWS ON BEHALF
OF ROUTE TO CHANGE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
ARE THERE ANY OTHER CALLS IN
THE QUEUE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU AND
WHAT THAT BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. MEMBERS C.NINE
MICHELIN WOULD LIKE CLOSE YEAH
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
AND FOR YOU AND YOUR STAFF HARD
WORK ON ON THIS LEGISLATION CAN
OF DOT COTTON EVEN HERE WITHOUT
YOU SO I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
IS A GREAT BILL TO SUPPORT OUR
LOCAL FOOD SYSTEM RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGHT OF. WELL I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT- MR BEAN
AND REALLY ENJOYED- ON ARTURO
WE WENT OUT THERE- TO VISIT-
THE- THE PROPONENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION- WHO IS. THAT YOU
KNOW A VERY EDUCATIONAL SO GLAD
THAT- YOU HAVE BROUGHT THIS
BILL FORWARD APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR WORK IT DOES HAVE A- A- DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION TO WITH
THAT IS OUR MOTION FOR THE OR
THERE WAS A MOTION BY THE
FLOOR. AND A SECOND BYE BYE
SURE MATHIS MAGIC TAPE WHO
PLEASECALL THE ROLL. ON ITEM
THREE AB EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
LEVINE MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS HI RIVAS AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE CUNNINGHAM
FLORA FLORA I AGREE. I AGREE I
OR ONE- AYE ONES SAWYER AND
SAWYER AYE LEVINE HI LEVINE I'D
BE A PUT OFF. BE ABLE TO WALK
ACT OF THEIR PRODRIVE WOULD.
WHAT I UNDERSTAND BOTH THE
THANK YOU ANSWER THAT- THE
CONCLUDES OUR MEETING BUT- YOUR
IF WE CAN OPEN UP FOR ADD ONS
MINUTES AFTER. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
FORWARD I AND ON ITEM TWO AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BLOOM WHICH
WAS- DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. WOOD I.
GOOD. SO NO MICHIGAN AND WILL
NOT BE COMING BACK SO WITH THAT
WE STAND ADJOURNED THANK YOU.